from a katana scent in the mail as a
low-key threat to 100
000 hand-drawn images there's a whole
lot you probably don't know about
Princess Mononoke
one of the most oft repeated Legends
surrounding Princess Mononoke concerns
the authorship of the English
translation four years it had been
rumored that famed British author Neil
Gaiman wrote the English translation of
the script but his name wasn't in the
credits so no one was really sure
finally in 2019 Gaiman took to Twitter
to confirm that the rumor was indeed
true he claimed that the reason his name
wasn't there was that when Studio Ghibli
asked that some of the Miramax
Executives be removed from the credits
they decided to remove gaiman's name
instead of removing their own
interestingly enough mirmax had
originally asked Quentin Tarantino to
rewrite the script when Tarantino turned
the job down he recommended Gaiman
instead gaiman's job would turn out to
be more difficult than one might imagine
as he had to deal with demands from
several sides first there were Hayao
miyazaki's demands for the script then
Miramax Executives and finally the
specific demands of notorious Miramax
Head Harvey Weinstein as film producer
Steve Alpert wrote in polygon the
bigwigs at Miramax thought American
audiences wouldn't accept certain
aspects of the film without significant
changes for example one mirror Max
executive thought audiences wouldn't
believe Prince ashtaka to be a prince at
all because he doesn't have a palace or
fancy clothes however Gaiman stuck to
his guns and wound up producing what's
often considered one of the best
translations of miyazaki's work
although Studio Ghibli has been
partnering with American Studios like
Disney and Miramax for many years now
these relationships haven't always gone
smoothly for understandable reasons
hayomiyazaki has often found himself
butting heads with Studio Executives who
want to change his films significantly
to satisfy the American Market in order
to maintain the Integrity of Princess
Mononoke as it went through the
translation process Miyazaki came up
with a list of Demands that he thought
needed to be included or excluded from
the English script according to Steve
Albert miyazaki's suggestions were often
about very specific ideas but he also
dispensed advice about casting Alpert
said that some of miyazaki's comments
were things like no modern slang and
choose good voices he also wanted to
make sure those involved in producing
the dub were aware of the cultural class
distinctions present in the film such as
the fact that ashtaka is a prince and
thus behaves in an old-fashioned manner
Miyazaki was also adamant that the
Firearms used in the film never be
called rifles or although that
instruction may have been Lost in
Translation judging by the final product
this is the late the later full that
I've asked these people to design the
ones we brought here have turned out to
be too heavy there's a famous urban
legend involving Princess Mononoke and a
sword and it happens to be mostly true
it's long been rumored that Hayao
Miyazaki sent a katana to Harvey
Weinstein as a threat while the American
dub was in production the truth is that
Miyazaki himself didn't send Weinstein a
threatening message but his producer did
as The Story Goes Weinstein was sent to
Katana in the mail and attached to the
sword were two simple words no Cuts this
was a serious worry as Weinstein was
known in the industry as Harvey
Scissorhands because of how much he
liked to cut from his Productions while
Miyazaki may not have sent the threat
himself he did meet with the now
disgraced Weinstein to hear his demands
he told the guardian I did go to New
York to meet this man this Harvey
Weinstein and I was bombarded with this
aggressive attack all these demands for
cuts I defeated him though we wouldn't
recommend sending swords through the
post office it's certainly an effective
way to get a message across to your
enemies
Princess Mononoke is an incredible feat
of animation and considering its lengthy
run time it's no surprise the film took
years to complete according to Miramax
only about 10 of the film is computer
animated which means the rest was drawn
by hand all in all over 144
000 animation cells were created for the
film one of the most impressive scenes
from an animation standpoint comes near
the beginning of the movie ashitaka
encounters a wild boar that's become
infected by a curse known as the
tataragami turning it into a terrifying
being covered in hundreds of snake-like
tendrils one fan of the movie took to
Twitter to ask Studio Ghibli about the
scene writing this has to be CG right
it's a fair assumption but it's totally
wrong Studio Ghibli responded to the
Tweet explaining the part where the
snakes move sluggishly was so difficult
that even though the scene is only a
couple of minutes long it took one year
and seven months to finish they noted
that it apparently took 5 5 300 drawings
to complete and one of the Ghibli
artists said it got more and more
confusing to draw as it went on that
painstaking effort definitely helped
make the scene as breathtaking as it is
the idea for the tataragami didn't come
from nowhere in an interview with Roger
Ebert hayo Miyazaki described how the
boar monster was meant to represent the
universal human emotion of Rage he
revealed I'm a very emotional person and
when I get enraged or Furious I feel
like black insects crawl out of my pores
my staff are more peaceful so it was
difficult for them to imagine what it
feels like to be taken over by
uncontrollable rage when Ebert asked if
the creature was based on his own
personal rage Miyazaki conceded that it
may be but he also explains that he
thinks rage and violence are deep-rooted
desires that all human beings possess
the director continued the issue we
confront as human beings is how to
control and manage that impulse though
some might want to Shield children from
these impulses Miyazaki has maintained
that it's important that they face this
reality as it's a part of all our lives
oh nameless God of rage and hate I my
bowel before you
Princess Mononoke contains many diverse
characters and thematic elements so it's
only fitting that Miyazaki took
inspiration from numerous sources
according to the official Princess
Mononoke website Miyazaki is a huge fan
of the American director John Ford who
was primarily known for making westerns
many of John Ford's films such as My
Darling Clementine take place in
Frontier Town something Miyazaki paid
homage to with the settlement of Iron
Town iron town is filled with outcasts
and outlaws who have the strength to
survive the tough environment of the
frontier much like in your standard
Western of course Princess Mononoke also
points out that the strength and
ambitious Mastery over one's domain
spells disaster and Destruction for the
environment which is exactly what lady
aboshi's hunt for the forest Spirit
represents
compared to his previous movies like
Kiki's Delivery Service and My Neighbor
Totoro Princess Mononoke is a strikingly
dark and serious film for hayo Miyazaki
speaking with Empire the director
described how risky the project was
especially considering his prior films
he explained that while working on
porico Rosso he learned of the war in
former Yugoslavia and was disappointed
that Humanity kept repeating the same
mistakes he explained after that we
couldn't go back and make some film like
Kiki's Delivery Service it felt like
children were being born to this world
without being blessed how could we
pretend to them that we're happy
Miyazaki has admitted that he exhausted
the animation team with the making of
Mononoke which he expected would happen
but even once the film was completed he
wasn't sure about who the audience was
he continued at first I decided this is
something children shouldn't see but in
the end I realized no this is something
that children must see because adults
they didn't get it children understood
it once Miyazaki realized the importance
of of the film he made he felt inspired
to keep making movies again
life is suffering it is hard the world
is cursed but still you find reasons to
keep living
in his list of requirements for the
English dub of the film hayo Miyazaki
implored the executives at Miramax to
choose good voices luckily casting
directors heated miyazaki's advice as
the English-speaking voice cast for the
film is filled with sultry voiced
Superstars Billy crudup voices ashitaka
Claire Danes voices San many driver
voices Lady aboshi Billy Bob Thornton
voices jacobo and Gillian Anderson
voices Moro Anderson was an especially
big get for the film as she was at the
height of her X-Files Fame when the
English dub premiered in 1999 at the
film films Premiere Anderson was asked
by hollywood.com about her familiarity
with miyazaki's films prior to starring
in Princess Mononoke to which she
explained that she'd been a fan of his
movies for years saying his films are
very spiritual and very beautiful and
very reverent as for whether she would
show the film to her children Anderson
wasn't sure at the time noting that
Princess Mononoke was much more intense
than his previous movies
lady eboshi may be the most interesting
character in Princess Mononoke as she's
a very complicated woman who's neither
all good nor all bad she has employed a
group of former sex workers and given
them important roles in the continued
functioning of Iron Town and she
provides a space for lepers who would be
turned away elsewhere at the same time
she's intent on furthering
industrialization at the expense of the
environment and she has no qualms about
killing the holy Forest Spirit when the
forest has been clear kid and the Wolves
wiped out this desolate place will be
the richest land in the world in a
Twitter q a with Van Studio Ghibli
answered a question about the
character's backstory the folks at
Ghibli revealed Miyazaki has said that
aboshi was sold as a slave and became
the wife of the leader of a band of
Japanese Pirates after she became a
skilled fighter she killed him stole his
treasure and returned to Mainland Japan
this backstory explains how lady eboshi
came to be The Confident competent woman
that she is and why she has such a
fondness for the former sex workers
employed in Iron Town several commenters
on Twitter noted what an interesting
character lady aboshi is with one fan
noting she's exactly like a modern
person she knows exactly what she has to
do to achieve her goals and has no
qualms about taking those actions
Studio Ghibli fans are often Keen to
draw connections between Hayao
miyazaki's many films and there's been a
persistent rumor that one such
connection exists between Princess
Mononoke and his 1988 movie My Neighbor
Totoro as The Story Goes the last
remaining tree Spirit at the end of
Princess Mononoke goes on to become one
of the Toros in the 1988 film although
Totoro came out before Mononoke it takes
place several hundred years later one
fan asked Studio Ghibli whether or not
this rumor is true on Twitter and the
studio answered during production it
seems that Miyazaki said something along
those lines to the staff while it may
not be a categorical yes it does seem
like there is a good chance that
Miyazaki did make the connection between
the two films himself at one point
either way it's fun to think about all
of miyazaki's movies existing in the
same universe or on the same timeline
while fans of Princess Mononoke might
spend much of their viewing time
marveling at the film's Magnificent
animation there are other elements of
the film that deserve plenty of
attention too sound design is an
important part of all filmmaking and
Studio Ghibli revealed a few fascinating
tidbits about this component of the film
during their Twitter q a Ghibli revealed
that the distinctive noise the tree
Spirits make was created using wooden
castanets as producers thought the
spirits should have a wood-like quality
about them due to their connection with
nature
[Music]
producer toshio Suzuki revealed that one
sound design element he's proud of can
be found during the fight between San
and Lady aboshi according to Suzuki they
spent a lot of time making sure Lydia
boshi's metal sword had a distinct sound
that was different from Sans dagger
which was made from bone this makes for
an excellent scene with some incredibly
Dynamic audio
in many reviews of the film critics have
praised Princess Mononoke for the way it
doesn't include an overly simplistic
happy ending in reference to the film's
somewhat ambiguous conclusion an
American journalist asked Tayo Miyazaki
if he thought of San and ashtaka as a
tragic couple because they can't be
together in response Miyazaki said they
remain involved I'm sure that they
maintain a good relationship so it seems
they aren't really the tragic Duo some
perceive them to be even though they
keep in touch Miyazaki imagined that the
future will not be easy for either of
them he explained that ashitaka will
help Sans stay alive but that he will
also dedicate himself to helping the
people of Iron Town and therein lies the
difficulty he continued and this will
tear ashtaka apart but this won't stop
him because he Treasures both Miyazaki
went on to say that this difficulty is
exactly the kind of lesson that
contemporary viewers can take from the
story it may not be a sappy happy ending
but according to the Creator himself
life indeed does go on
foreign